is this whitney coming because
i literally texted you like last month
saying is this real
and then i think i deleted your contacts
and then
you said yes so i'm guessing this is you
is this the future of our country i just
want to say hi hi
maybe if you could like give me a shout
out you know
we don't know your name yeah i'm just
doing my nails right now and you're on
oh so don't worry hear me
sorry if you can't hear me really bored
that sounds like your problem
i'm just really bored um that would be
really fun i know you get like a bunch
of messages from
a bunch of old men we don't get a lot of
these messages or any of those kinds of
messages
yes i stop her i get plenty of messages
from young people
all the time that aren't doing their
nails that aren't bored
i'm really bored i'm doing my nails
right now sorry if you can't hear me
sounds like your problem boomer
do you like how that went from like um
uh is this whitney to bitch i know you
ain't getting no messages like this
stupid ass hoe oh bitch like you're like
it went from like hi big fan to like
bitch you should be so lucky yeah just
um and you wish i was gonna call you
don't you she's been listening to our
podcast too much
she says to herself if it's too high and
i love you and i think you're
fucking hilarious bitch like fuck like
you're fucking funny
um i'm not gonna leave you creepy
messages cause that's
i'm just like really nervous because
you're kind of like saying this and i
don't really know what kind of kind
this has been the most flattering
insulting voicemail i've ever heard
like on youtube like your comedy um
and yeah so hit me up girl my name is
nancy i live in la now
and um i did not think her name was you
know nancy paul girl and we could make
tick tocks and excuse me we have that
covered
the self-esteem is unbelievable hey i
mean
call me bye you fucking hilarious
bitch fuck you sorry
what you're welcome i'll have you know
that we do tick-tocks
that's our thing i'm so confused is that
what self-esteem sounds like
i don't that sounds like ritalin i think
riddle and some boomer shit i think
that's adderall
oh yeah that's what i mean what are you
doing what am i talking about that's
monster energy i was trying to relate
adderall and listening to too much
rihanna and having way too much
self-worth
oh okay we love that's just like such
that's like young people now like just
you're welcome i'm talking to you
whereas my generation is like i'm sorry
i'm so sorry about oh yeah so sorry to
bother you that's true millennials are
like i'll leave and then um
you can only be so lucky pleasure
bitch